nous quittons la Meurthe-et-Moselle la
ville de Baccarat et c'est que 4600
habitants ont été tournés ce
documentaire réalisé par Joseph gorillo
là-bas comme 5 ans plus tôt Marine Le
Pen est arrivé largement en tête lors de
la dernière élection présidentielle
l'occasion de nous interroger plus
au-delà sur les comportements électoraux
dans la France d'aujourd'hui surtout
chez ceux dont on parle peu ou dont on
ne parle pas c'est ce que nous allons
faire maintenant sur ce plateau de débat
doc en compagnie de nos invités Brice
teinturiers pour commencer bienvenue
vous êtes directeur général délégué
dipso c'est enseignant à Sciences Po on
vous doit entre autres plus rien à faire
plus rien à la vraie crise de la
démocratie un ouvrage que vous avez
publié chez Robert Lafont et qui a
d'ailleurs obtenu le Prix du Livre
politique en 2017 fait déjà 5 ans mais
c'était pourtant prémonitoire ce titre
on y reviendra sans doute tout à l'heure
frémit Lefebvre est également avec nous
bienvenue
vous êtes politiste c'est un terme que
vous préférez d'ailleurs à politologue
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'Université de l'île d'eux et chercheur
au Centre d'études et de recherche
administrative politique et sociale
c'est le séraps votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule lui faut-il désespérer de la
gauche et il est disponible aux éditions
textuelles enfin anne Muxel est avec
nous bienvenue à vous vous êtes
sociologue et politologue directrice de
recherche en sociologie et en sciences
politiques au CNRS au CEVIPOF pour être
plus précis et spécialiste du rapport
des jeunes à la politique votre dernier
livre s'intitule Une jeunesse engagée
enquête sur les étudiants de Sciences Po
2002-2022 disponible au presse de
Sciences Po et co-écrit avec Martial
Foucault qui dirige d'ailleurs le
CEVIPOF une carte tout d'abord si vous
pour situer baccara sur une carte de
France Baccarat vous le voyez sur cette
carte c'est c'est pas très loin de Nancy
dans la région Grand Est bien sûr
Baccarat qui compte quelques 4600
habitants je les dis dans notre
présentation et puis regardez ce qu'on
était les résultats au second tour de la
présidentielle de 2017 pour commencer
Marine Le Pen arrivé en tête de ce
second tour avec
54,75 % des voix Emmanuel Macron réalisé
un score de 45,25% des voix d'abstention
c'est le fait quant à elle a 28,63% et
puis voici maintenant le résultat de ce
qui a été l'élection présidentielle de
2022 sur cette élection pense évidemment
le film que nous avons vu Marine Le Pen
arrive cette fois toujours en tête mais
avec 59,2 % des voix autrement dit déjà
pratiquement plus de 5 points du score
qu'elle avait réalisé en 2017 Emmanuel
Macron totally's 40,8% des voix
l'abstention est en hausse de trois
points par rapport à 2017 à
31,56% et puis pour changer le
documentaire que nous venons de voir
voici ce qui a été les résultats cette
fois de l'élection législative de 2022
et bien vous voyez qu'au second tour
c'est le candidat les républicains
Thibault Bazin qui l'a emporté avec 52,9
% des voix face au représentants du
rassemblement national Dominique Bild
qui totalise lui
47,1% des voix et regardez ce cette
abstention au second tour de ces
législatifs 62 % d'abstention dans cette
ville de Baccarat
brise teinturier on a envie de commencer
par savoir ce qui vous est vu
immédiatement à l'esprit après avoir vu
ce film qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit du
comportement électoral
auquel on doit faire face qu'on doit
commenter aujourd'hui dans notre pays
alors d'abord comment est-ce qu'il nous
le dit moi je trouve qu'il nous le dit
avec une force une puissance qui tient
la puissance du témoignage on a beaucoup
de choses beaucoup de données dans les
une étude sondage dans la recherche sur
ce qui se passe dans les milieux
populaires sur leur rapport à la
politique mais là la puissance du
témoignage ou on ne pose même pas de
questions on laisse parler les gens et
bien je trouve permet de tout comprendre
et avec véritablement un effet de
réalité qui est extraordinaire lorsqu'on
voit c'est la béance bien sûr la béance
de la relation entre les gens qui vivent
et que vous avez filmé et le monde
politique la coupure a commencéurale on
voit de manière magistrale la difficulté
à se projeter l'impossibilité à se
projeter dans l'avenir tout est un peu
triste non dans ce documentaire dans
cette vie il y a peu de choses joyeuses
il y a peu d'espoir il y a peu
d'espérance il y a un sentiment de
relégation d'abandon qui est extrêmement
impuissant et puis il y a énormément
d'autres choses qu'on comprend par
petite touche des expressions comme ces
trucs au moment des résultats
cette idée que il y a des gens qui
manipulent
on voit le complotisme qui est présent
aussi
l'antisémitisme qui affleure à certains
moments et surtout je crois l'espèce de
désespérance le sentiment qu'il y a de
monde le monde d'enroule le monde des
politiques notre monde probablement et
puis une sorte de vraie réalité pour eux
et qui est à 100 milieux et ce que je
trouve très puissant aussi presque
touchant ce sont les personnes qui se
retirent du film comme si la parole
n'avait même plus de capacité à réunir
ces deux mondes comme si ces personnes
se sentaient tellement loin qu'il n'est
plus utile plus besoin d'expliquer ou de
parler donc c'est vraiment un
documentaire très très puissant sur ce
sentiment d'abandon et de relégation et
là vous parlez effectivement d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont été
interviewées une première fois puis qui
ont décidé d'arrêter les interviews pour
la suite de ce film on va voir un
extrait il est 20h vous disiez élection
truquée on va revoir cet extrait où
quelqu'un s'interroge c'est truqué c'est
pas possible il est 20 h c'est le
résultat du premier tour de cette
présidentielle 2022 à Baccarat
Emmanuel Macron c'est pas possible
respectivement vous le voyez 28
truqué tout le monde est contre lui
les gilets jaunes que ça soit les
infirmières tous les gendarmes ils
limitent tous contre lui maintenant oui
tout le monde est contre
déplacement il est hué
il est il se fait jeter des merdes des
objets des trucs comme ça et il a 28%
c'est pas possible
les trucs et ainsi le fameux extrait
dont vous parliez puis Rémi les fêtes
j'ai vu quelque part que vous disiez à
la suite de ces élections la figure de
Macron est répulsive dans les classes
populaires il est jugé comme un Parisien
hautain avec du mépris de classe
ça corroborce convient de voir là
finalement il y a deux choses il y a
l'image de Macron effectivement qui
apparaît dans à plusieurs reprises comme
très très République dans le
documentaire et on voit à quel point
dans ces milieux populaires ce
qu'incarme Macron son style son
vocabulaire son extraction
les sociologues diraient sont Nexis son
langage corporel et à des années-lumière
de leur univers elle limite le Macron
c'est même pas tant ses orientations
politiques qui peuvent faire problème
dans ces milieux là c'est effectivement
un langage à une condescendance un style
qui en fait voilà les rebuts les les
révoltes etc alors ce qui est dingue
vraiment dans cet extrait parce qu'il
est assez fascinant cet extrait c'est
aussi de dire voilà
social et sociologique qui détermine en
fait la perception du monde social et
qui fait qu'à un moment donné outre la
défiance phénoménale qui ressort
du documentaire parce que ça un des mots
clés quand même de documentaire c'est
défiance défiance vis-à-vis des
journalistes des chiffres des sciences
de tout évidemment la défiance aussi
vis-à-vis des chiffres les chiffres sont
trucs les élections sont truqués la
guerre et truqué le covid c'était pas
qu'est-ce que c'était voilà donc du coup
même même le verdict électoral fait
problème Brice Teinturier évoqué les
fractures qu'incarne ce film fracture
sociale fracture territoriale sans doute
vous êtes de cet avis c'est ce que vous
avez vu en regardant ce film aussi un
mixeur oui un grand abandon ça ça a été
dit un grand abandon une grande distance
je trouve que formellement le
documentaire rend très bien compte de
cette distance
qui existe aujourd'hui entre une grande
majorité de Français et un autre monde
un monde éloigné effectivement le monde
de la politique
et par par son propos par son montage
par ces
ce parti pris d'une unité
unité de lieu dans le cadre de sa
réflexion c'est à dire on part du camion
pizza qui dure reste et un endroit qui
marque le dernier lieu de de sociabilité
de rencontre des gens donc on ressent
d'autant plus avec ce camion pizza que
en dehors de ce camion pizza finalement
il y a il y a pas grand chose les gens
sont effectivement
enfermés dans un univers social dans un
territoire
dont il n'arrive pas à sortir il y a
même un moment donné un des une des
personnes qui qui dit moi de ma vie et
qui est déjà assez âgée puisqu'il va
prendre sa retraite je ne suis jamais
allé ailleurs mais même pas dans le sud
sa fille ou une belle fille lui dit même
pas dans le Sud alors qu'elle elle va
effectivement aller à Port-Barcarès et
là on prend la mesure effectivement de
de l'aspect statique enfermé distant
d'une grande partie de la population qui
ne connaît absolument pas les modes de
vie on va dire
ils ne sont pas dominants puisque
justement une domine pas mais ils sont
en tout cas les plus partagées dans les
médias les plus représentés et donc je
crois que le film vraiment est très fort
là-dessus parce que vraiment cette
distance sociale en même temps que la
distance politique est vraiment
manifeste elle est colossale et autre
chose quand même qui m'a aussi beaucoup
frappé c'est on voit bien que la vie
quotidienne de ces personnes et rythmées
par quelques euros on vit à quelques
euros près il faut compter surtout il y
a un moment que je trouve aussi assez
terrible de dans le meilleur des cas on
arrive à boucler le mois le 20 du mois
mais on va pas au-delà du vin du mois
des indicateurs très éducatifs du VO
c'est à dire tous ceux qui ont nous
disent dans nos enquêtes par exemple
qu'ils ont du mal à boucler les fins de
moi ou qu'ils vivent à crédit voter
majoritairement pour Marine Le Pen la
barrière elle se fait aussi à ce niveau
là et vous souvenez dans le documentaire
cette personne qui sur la mécanique
récupère un phare ça fait 20 euros ça
fait 30 euros mais qui nous dit que la
mécanique non c'est absolument pas une
passion c'est pas du bricolage c'est un
moyen de survie de gagner quelques euros
et on est systématiquement dans cette
obsession du lendemain ou du quotidien
sur le voyage à Disney sur l'idée
d'aller à Disney mais ça coûte 150 euros
le décompte du parking et ça c'est une
réalité qu'on connaît on ne sait par des
chiffres par des indicateurs mais mais
là et c'est encore une fois la force du
documentaire il y a cette espèce de vécu
au quotidien du rapport à l'argent et au
manque qui qui est extrêmement puissant
et très explicatif alors Marine Le Pen
avant de vous donner la parole Rémi le
fait il a évidemment beaucoup question
parce qu'on vote Marine Le Pen en partie
évidemment et même en grande partie à
Baccarat nouvelle extrait du
documentaire avec un personnage dans ce
film un habitant de Baccarat qui nous en
parle de Marine Le Pen
va conduire le pays à la faillite
ils sont complètement fous
qui sait comment en train de nous mettre
au fond du trou c'est
le Macron là jamais on y a été aussi
vite au fond du trou
il la font passer comme un Hitler c'est
fini ça
[Applaudissements]
ils la font passer comme un Hitler c'est
fini ça voilà ce que ce que nous dit cet
homme qui témoigne dans ce film c'est la
dédiabolisation
vécue dans ce reportage finalement de du
rassemblement national et et de sa
leader que Marine Le Pen le même
personnage je crois que c'est le même
qu'on voit un moment donné est allé en
fait les professions de foi et quand ils
voient Zemmour il dit il parle d'Hitler
et donc là on voit aussi la
dédiabolisation qui s'est opérée
relationnellement par rapport à Zemmour
c'est-à-dire très clairement la Zemmour
on le place à l'extrême et on voit qu'il
a donc eu un effet de modéré de
modération de l'offre Marine Le Pen et
effectivement il y a ce discours qui est
de dire
effectivement elle est perçue comme une
candidate alors comme une candidate qui
n'a pas encore été au pouvoir donc ça
c'est ça apparaît à plusieurs reprises
c'est en finalement cette usure
généralisé de toutes les familles
politiques et on a tout essayé et elle
apparaît comme extérieur en fait
extérieur au jeu politique extérieur aux
institutions alors c'est là c'est
stupéfiant alors que même Marine Le Pen
c'est le produit aussi du système
politique c'est quelqu'un parce que ça
ça paraît aussi beaucoup qui a aussi une
condition parlementaire parce que les
avantages des hommes politiques parce
que c'est dit à plusieurs reprises le
chauffeur les 5000 euros c'est à dire
que non seulement il y a la perception
évidemment de qu'on est des gens de peu
qu'on est dans la nécessité mais
évidemment ce qui est perçu c'est pas le
patron le mot patron n'est pas prononcé
dans le documentaire c'est les élites
politiques voilà et donc effectivement
Marine Le Pen elle apparaît dans une
extériorité en fait à ce système et donc
évidemment il y a aussi l'idée que elle
est éprouvée comme nous donc il y a une
identification aussi à cette réprobation
était disqualification dont elle fait
l'objet et donc effectivement alors
juste je termine il y a des fois des
fois on n'ose pas dire qu'on est pendant
Marine Le Pen parce qu'il y a quand même
encore un peu ça et puis parfois on
l'affirme donc effectivement il y a
aussi maintenant une dès qu'on est
décomplexé à dire qu'on peut voter pour
Marine Le Pen je voulais évidemment vous
parler du vote des jeunes je voudrais
savoir qui parmi les jeunes les 18 24
ans ou peut-être au-delà de 24 ans
jusqu'à 30 ans vote Le Pen et pourquoi
aujourd'hui oui ce sont d'ailleurs
plutôt les 24 35 qui votent Le Pen c'est
moins les tout jeune
alors c'est pas non plus du tout tous
les jeunes on observe dans le vote jeune
des fractures sociales culturelles
territoriales très importantes la
question du niveau de diplôme est
absolument décisive donc il faut faire
attention quand on parle votre jeune la
jeunesse c'est effectivement n'est pas
du tout un groupe socialement ni
politiquement homogène donc on trouve
effectivement ce vote pour Marine Le Pen
plus marquée dans les segments de la
jeunesse peu diplômés
galérant sur le marché le marché du
travail dans des emplois peu ou pas
qualifiés bon je rajoute à ça aussi que
c'est aussi dans ces segments de la
jeunesse ce que l'on observe les taux
d'abstention les plus les plus
importants c'est à dire que la
désespérance sociale à des espérances
politiques en tout cas chez les jeunes
elle se marquent aussi par par une
abstention beaucoup plus
des jeunes c'est vrai que lorsqu'on est
jeune c'est étayé d'ailleurs dans les
chiffres on vote plutôt aux extrêmes du
spectre
mais en l'occurrence à cette
présidentielle de 2022 les jeunes ont
d'abord voté Mélenchon pour ceux qui ont
voté et ensuite ils ont voté pour Marine
Le Pen et enfin pour Emmanuel Macron
voilà c'est dans l'ordre c'est cela un
changement par rapport à 2017
pour Marine Le Pen et ensuite pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc il y a
effectivement un changement par contre
chez les 24 35 ans le moment où les
jeunes entre justement dans la vie
adulte dans la vie professionnelle où
ils sont confrontés à des difficultés
considérables et notamment les
difficultés économiques alors on trouve
un vote pour Marine Le Pen plus plus
marquée le vote Marine Le Pen il faut il
faut l'expliquer
d'un point de vue sociologique alors
chez les jeunes effectivement peut-être
les les moins fortunés les plus
précaires c'est vrai aussi du côté
adulte il trouve les employés les
ouvriers les cadres les employés ça
progresse également chez les professions
intermédiaires et les cadres mais le
cœur du dispositif c'est quand même les
employés les ouvriers toujours les
petits plomés le rural ou le périurbain
qui a beaucoup voté pour Marine Le Pen
et beaucoup plus ça pas toujours été le
cas souvenez-vous en 95 les scores du
Front national c'était plutôt dans les
grandes villes ça s'est progressivement
inversé donc votre reportage Baccarat
c'est un condensé de tout ça mais plutôt
vous il y avait un temps on aurait voté
Parti communiste on aurait même voté
politique plutôt que de voter
ou droites traditionnel aussi
conservatrice mais dans les leviers du
vote Le Pen je trouve que ce qu'on voit
à nouveau très bien dans le documentaire
c'est qu'il y a il y a non seulement
deux mondes mais Marine Le Pen allait de
notre côté c'est elle est chez nous elle
nous comprend et l'autre monde il ne
nous comprend pas vous avez repassé la
séquence sur les résultats électoraux et
que dit la personne mais il est fou lui
et il est fou c'est la figure de
l'altérité c'est l'autre il utilise ces
termes donc en permanence vous avez
cette cette logique il y a les autres et
il y a nous et Marine Le Pen elle fait
partie de ceux qui nous comprennent elle
est de notre côté et finalement c'est la
différence avec Éric Zemmour mais c'est
la seule dans le système politique et
dans le système de candidature qui donne
ce sentiment au milieu populaire
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est différent il y
a encore d'autres ressorts et ce ne sont
pas ceux-là et c'est ce qui explique
aussi en grande partie la progression
continue mais là la poussée de Marine Le
Pen en 2022 vous connaissez bien les
hauts de France vous y enseigné là
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il y a des
comparaisons possibles avec les scores
réalisés dans ce qui est aujourd'hui
présenter un peu comme un fief de Marine
Le Pen en l'occurrence cette région
Hauts-de-France et la région Grand Est
ce vote effectué à bakara qu'on a vu
dans ce film avec le département là du
documentaire il y a c'est une tradition
de droite quand même plutôt ce qui est
intéressant par comparaison avec les
hauts de France c'est que là les hauts
de France la droite y est inexistante
historiquement ça c'est un coin où la
droite a toujours été très faible et où
c'est un bastion du Parti socialiste et
du Parti communiste donc c'est vrai
c'est pas les mêmes lieux populaires
c'est des milliers populaires dans le
nord de région désindustrialisée c'est à
dire que là le sentiment de relégation
c'est aussi le sentiment du déclin d'une
activité qui était l'activité minière
qui était structurante avec aussi dans
les Hauts-de-France indiscrédit de la
classe politique notamment socialiste
des des scandales politiques qui ont
nourri les victoires à Hénin-Beaumont ou
plus récemment à bruit en Artois et
c'est pas les mêmes milieux populaires
c'est des milieux populaires dans les
hauts de France qui sont plus
précarisées parce que là en fait Bruce
teinturier a dit il y a c'est l'altérité
Macron il y a aussi un autre ressort du
vote pour Marine Le Pen c'est aussi la
lutte contre les assistés c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui les milieux populaires
ils se situent par rapport à ceux qui
sont en haut c'est-à-dire eux les élites
effectivement donc là c'est Macron la
figure mais aussi par rapport à ceux qui
sont en bas en sociologie on dit que
c'est une conscience triangulaire voilà
et ceux qui sont en bas c'est les
assister et à un moment donné ça a été
évoqué dans le dans le dans le
documentaire c'est à dire que finalement
les gens qui travaillent qui qui en
bavent etc le vote le vote aussi pour
Marine Le Pen c'est un vote pour se
distinguer des kassos des gens qui sont
tout en bas des gens qui vivent des
revenus d'assistance et c'est ça qui est
un carburant extraordinairement puissant
du vote de Marine Le Pen c'est que
Marine Le Pen allait à la fois des gens
qui votent contre
des élites d'en haut mais aussi contre
les pauvres d'en bas et c'est ce mélange
et et aujourd'hui ce mélange en plus il
est à s'ajoute s'ajoute ça aussi des
gens qui ne votaient pas avant pour le
rassemblement national qui vote
maintenant pour le rassemblement
national je donne juste un chiffre qui
est très parlant au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle il y a un prof
sur 4 qui a voté pour Marine Le Pen un
prof sur 4 25% les profs il y a 30 ans
il votait à 3% donc c'est un vote donc
on vote de plus en plus Marine Le Pen
dans la fonction publique par exemple
voilà c'est un vote effectivement situé
socialement mais de plus en plus attrape
tout et interclassistes
chez les jeunes il y a pas de référence
forcément historique la conscience
politique se construit lorsqu'on a 18 20
ans et de ses premiers votes lors de ses
premiers votes lorsqu'on est jeune on
vote Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui parce
qu'on ne connaît peut-être pas ce qui
est historique de l'extrême droite en
France par exemple
oui bien sûr on vote Marine Le Pen
d'abord par
anti-système c'est un vote protestataire
ça a beaucoup été étudié analysé comme
cela et un vote
anti-élite effectivement aussi un vote
c'est pas le tout on a tout essayé ces
jeunes parce que bah eux ils ont pas
tout essayé par nature c'est leur
premier vol leur deuxième vote c'est pas
ça Marine Le Pen a su envoyer pas mal de
signaux en direction de la jeunesse elle
a par exemple formée et mis à des
positions de de représentation dans les
conseils municipaux des tout jeunes elle
a elle a elle a eu une politique très
active en matière de représentation
politique par le RN des jeunes justement
et donc là je pense que je pense que ça
ça a été pour elle une assise à la
possibilité d'une assise électorale
assez importante dans la jeunesse et
puis n'oublions pas ça a été bien montré
d'ailleurs il y a une petite séquence
avec l'enfant qui montre bien
l'impact que peuvent avoir des parents
des paroles de parents sur des enfants
tout jeune en fait il y a maintenant
toute une génération de jeunes qui a
entendu leur parent tenir des propos
tels que ceux que l'on entend dans ce
documentaire c'est-à-dire le
désenchantement la désillusion tous
pourris et puis pourquoi pas Marine Le
Pen pourquoi on lui donnerait pas une
chance elle elle pourrait peut-être
faire quelque chose elle était passage
sur l'immigration
l'immigré l'étranger alors parce que je
pense que cette département n'est pas
aussi une grande terre d'immigration
mais finalement c'est pas ça une heure
de documentaire la figure de l'étranger
et de l'immigré et totalement absente en
fait comme enfin
le vote rassemblement national dans le
sud-est de la France par exemple si je
veux poursuivre là sur la sur justement
la transmission la socialisation ça veut
dire que la
de Marine Le Pen et du rassemblement
national elle elle a pénétré aussi la
dynamique générationnelle elle c'est
elle commence maintenant à être
transmise dans dans la famille et les
touts qui vont voter ne voient pas le
problème puisque chez eux ils ont
effectivement entendu qu'il y avait
légitimité à et bien adhérer à Marine Le
Pen et rassemblement national donc ça je
crois que c'est c'est aussi un élément
qui explique le vote des jeunes pour
certains jeunes notamment dans les
catégories populaires pour Marine Le Pen
alors ce qui frappe aussi mais c'était
pas dit dans ce documentaire encore que
certains dans ce film disait qu'il
n'allait pas aller voter mais ce qui a
beaucoup frappé évidemment c'est le
niveau de l'abstention à l'occasion de
ces présidentielles et également au
législatives qui auront suivi je vais
rappeler le titre de votre livre Brice
Teinturier plus rien à faire plus rien à
la vraie crise de la démocratie
c'est vrai que c'était prémonitoire vous
l'avez écrit il y a 5 ans ce livre un
peu plus pas de temps 6 ans
c'est aussi un petit peu ce qu'on
ressent après avoir vu ce film c'est une
crise démocratique et une défiance
vis-à-vis de la politique c'est sans
titre non à l'époque moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'était pas le
rassemblement en fin de Front national à
l'époque il y avait beaucoup de choses
qui étaient produites sur le front
national je trouvais qu'il y avait un
phénomène qui n'était pas en revanche
assez étudiée et qui minait la
démocratie d'une manière tout aussi
importante et qui était cette distance
incommensurable et ce sentiment de
auront les amarres c'est stratégie de
sortie on en a plus rien à faire voir
plus rien à dans une version un
peu plus rugueuse on ne va pas forcément
ou pour autant sur des des votes de
contestation à la périphérie du système
on se retire et c'est ce qu'on retrouve
évidemment principalement aussi non une
partie des motivations des
abstentionnistes l'idée que ça ne sert à
rien une déception incommensurable qui a
d'abord été nourri par les premières
alternances l'alternance de 81 qui avait
suscité énormément a tué l'espérance 83
84 ça a laissé des marques profondes et
ensuite vous avez eu à partir des années
2000 ce sentiment que non seulement les
alternances se ressemblaient mais qu'en
plus elle ne produisait pas de résultats
sur les enjeux essentiels de l'emploi du
pouvoir d'achat ou l'immigration donc
Nicolas Sarkozy essayer de réactiver
l'idée du résultat c'est fait rattraper
par la crise du résultat et ensuite vous
avez la crise de la représentation les
deux combinés fabriquent ce sentiment
que ce n'est même plus la peine d'aller
voter que le canal de représentation par
le vote ne fonctionne plus ne sert plus
et on voit de manière assez linéaire à
toutes les élections y compris les
élections dites de proximité des maires
on voit une augmentation régulière de
l'abstention donc soit par contestation
soit tout simplement par prise de
distance grandissante mais ce qui est
nouveau et ce qui m'a frappé je reviens
quand même une seconde sur votre portage
c'est cette idée aussi qu'on formate les
esprits les gens dans le reportage
vivent
ils sont formatés on nous formatent les
médias formatent les gens etc et ça vous
ne l'aviez pas dans le vote du Front
national pas à ce point il y a 30 ans
bien sûr qu'il y avait les stablishment
selon Jean-Marie Le Pen qui avait
toujours un système médiatique on disait
le système médiatique qui jouait contre
le Front national mais là on a
l'impression que ça imprégné
ces personnes et qu'elles ont la
certitude de elle savoir ce qu'est le
réel c'est nous qui sommes manipulés
et elle nous le disent comme ça donc ça
ça devient extraordinairement compliqué
d'avoir ensuite une controverse sur des
faits partagés une réalité partagée
parce que la béance est extrêmement
forte y compris dans le rapport à
l'information donc quand vous n'avez
plus le résultat quand vous n'avez pas
d'information quand vous n'avez pas la
représentation mais j'ai envie de dire
vous vous tirez et c'est ce qu'ils font
sur cette abstention
grandissante élection après l'élection y
compris sur ces élections majeures la
présidentielle en France c'est
c'est l'élection avec un grand E en même
temps on voit pas on voit pas le trop de
désintérêt alors forcément peut-être que
on a retenu les images mais ils ont
l'air quand même intéressé par la
campagne un peu excités
en France c'était seulement la deuxième
fois sous la 5e donc il y a un
désintérêt il y a dans tous les cas il y
a aucune illusion en fait ça c'est clair
à un moment donné c'est c'est dit à un
moment donné sur Marine Le Pen bon c'est
pas sûr on vote pour elle mais le vote
Marine Le Pen c'est aussi un vote des
investi un petit peu c'est-à-dire on
vote contre on vote par aussi par défaut
notamment au deuxième tour non mais sur
l'ascension
il y a une classe politique qui n'est
pas à l'image des citoyens il y a la
crise du résultat les problèmes ne sont
pas résolus donc la politique est
impuissante il y a une classe politique
qui pourtant s'accroche en fait à ces
mandats alors qu'elle n'en fait elle
n'en fait pas grand chose voilà il y a
aussi effectivement une complexité aussi
de l'afropolitique ça c'est frappant un
moment donné j'essaie de rebondir sur le
reportage il regarde en fait les
professions de foi Fabien Roussel il
connaît pas Fabien Roussel bon Fabien
Roussel oui on est des gens très numéro
dominé la gauche française le Parti
communiste des années après l'offre
politique c'est considérablement
complexifié ces dernières années il y a
énormément de parties à gauche il y a il
y a des des outsiders comme Macron qui
ont un moment donné brouillé les cartes
donc les coûts d'entrée les coûts de
compréhension en fait de cet univers
politique qui est qui suscite la
défiance sont de plus en plus élevés
donc c'est pas quand on n'est pas très
intéressé par la politique et ça reste
quand même la norme c'est à dire que les
gens qui sont très intéressés par la
politique dans la société ils sont pas
nombreux et quand en plus il faut
s'intéresser à quelque chose qui est
associé à quelque chose de sale quelque
chose de
répugnant de considère pas bien et qu'en
plus qu'on considère que ça sert à rien
et qu'en fait on a aussi l'impression
que voter c'est cautionner le système
tout ça c'est des mécanis des puissants
mécanismes qui désincitent à participer
à de Bruxelles voulait évoquiez tout à
l'heure
l'abstentionnisme chez les jeunes c'est
un c'est un fait remarquable et
remarquer dans les chiffres aussi 41%
des 18 24 ans n'ont pas été voté au
second tour de la présidentielle c'est
presque 1/2
là aussi on a un problème peut-être des
relations des jeunes avec les politiques
et la politique oui c'est à dire que
l'abstention
réelle à la fois une situation
effectivement dans certains endroits
comme le territoire où se passent ce
documentaire d'anomie finalement
d'anomie sociale et politique c'est une
abstention de de retrait d'abstention
hors du jeu politique ou s'exprime cette
distance très forte à l'égard du système
mais il y a aussi une abstention qui est
de nature protestataire qui est une
abstention
intermittente qui correspond au vote
intermittent c'est à dire que voilà le
le le vote a perdu de son de son
caractère systématique comme devant
relever du devoir du citoyen et donc
cette affaiblissement de la norme
civique on va dire du devoir de voter et
bien chez les jeunes qui sont entrés en
politique dans un moment où l'abstention
ne cessait d'augmenter et bien c'est un
comportement qui est adopté par eux de
façon plus facile avec moi ils sont ils
sont ils se sentent moins dans une
situation de réprobation sociale s'il ne
vote pas et d'ailleurs le devoir d'aller
voter souvent quelque chose sur il
fallait voter par deux voir on va voter
c'est des jeunes ça marche moins bien ça
aujourd'hui on va davantage voter chez
les pour les jeunes parce que l'on veut
exercer un droit un droit d'expression
voilà mais on veut aussi revendiquer
éventuellement le droit de ne pas voter
pour exprimer un mécontentements une
protestations une insatisfaction par
rapport à l'offre électorale qui peut
être proposée et qui effectivement de
plus en plus complexe à intégrer comme a
été dit les jeunes ne semblent pas se
retrouver dans cette offre électorale
lorsqu'on regarde les études
qualitatives ils ne
trouvent pas leur compte en terme de
d'offres électorale oui là faudrait
faire ouvrir un nouveau un nouveau débat
parce que c'est compliqué par exemple
les jeunes qui sont très préoccupés ou
en tout cas une partie de la jeunesse
alors là je reviens sur la jeunesse
étudiante très préoccupé par exemple par
l'enjeu écologique ils votent pas autant
pour le pour les candidats écologiques
ou pour les parties écologiques donc
c'est compliqué effectivement la la
perception par les jeunes de l'offre de
l'offre politique et complexe difficile
et sans doute leur perplexité est assez
grande on verra ce qu'il en sera pour
les prochains scrutins les scrutins qui
sont devant nous serons les Européennes
et pas seulement en France d'ailleurs
pour le coup un scooter européen ça sera
partout chez les chez les 27 merci un
grand merci vraiment à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission
aujourd'hui après ce documentaire
intitulé sobrement eux mais tu donnais
beaucoup pas voir sur ce qui s'est passé
à Baccarat lors de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
je compte sur vous pour réagir à ce que
ce qu'on sait réactions à mon avis il va
y en avoir quelques-unes merci à sel
massali qui m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et puis moi je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un prochain le Badoc et
ça sera bien sûr avec son documentaire
et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]